so I heard from one Police Plaza they
received my letter and apparently they
also received hundreds of others in
support of CJ yeah Emily and I sent
those ins Emily what was that burn I had
you write down for AMA because I didn't
want to forget it why so sad did you
just find out American Girl doesn't make
clothes in adult sizes no Steven Segal
called and he wants his ponytail back
huh Gina : hey Amy what did one graphing
calculator say to the other one Amy :
what Gina : why does this said lady oh
you know what
congratulations you just made sure that
a terrible captain will be sticking
around here indefinitely no Santiago
we're just trying to make the best of it
no never
[Music]
Madeline thank you for coming
Raymond oh is the pleasure to call on a
vanquished foe I feel like Jackie
joyner-kersee congratulating one of the
other slower runners buckle up it's
gonna be a hell of a ride Curtis it I'm
sure you'd like to take some weight off
your cloven hooves calling me the devil
how original Raymond actually I was
calling you a goat the goat you have
until tomorrow you grackle I may not be
the man for the job you used to be the
precincts champion marksman I only want
to take pointers from the best so I'll
keep it low-key we'll go after work to a
private range no cops no pressure range
I told Gina she could join us I don't
want to get certified there's been a ton
of crime in my neighborhood and the cops
of my precinct are very bad you live in
our precinct yeah I know believe you
Crawford just got off the elevator my
arrival for the Commissioner ship she's
here right now I've got to come up with
a confident opening salvo think Raymond
Fink hello Raymond Olivia you have a
little bit of goop in your eye oh thank
you I'm sorry to barge in like this but
I have a source on the nominating
committee they're making their
recommendation to the mayor at the end
of next week and it seems that John
Kelly is going to beat out both of us
big shocker the straight white man wins
again
that was my complaint about Owen winning
Top Chef junior and you guys all acted
like I was crazy half of the committee
supports John Kelly and the other half
is divided between the two of us we're
splitting the vote so for either of us
to have a chance one of us needs to step
aside exactly you should drop it is what
you said to yourself in the mirror this
morning instead of checking your eye for
goop and I agree you should drop out is
what you said to yourself in the mirror
this morning while polishing your head
don't you think it's time New York had
its first female Commissioner what about
its first openly gay Commissioner yes
that would be vital and important if you
weren't 1 million years old you do know
that exaggeration is the hucksters
crutch also I come off quite youthful
you just said hucksters crutch step
aside grandpa for you and you and you
what are they these madam are STDs what
are you talking about buddy
STDs save the dates for Vivian on my
wedding ah yes hey just out of curiosity
how many people have you given STDs two
lots
like a hundred what's going on oh okay I
get it
STD has another meaning you're gross no
one else is gonna think that everyone is
going to think that but it's sweet that
your mind didn't go there thank you it
is kind of sweet well your first dance
beats you you give me fever will you be
seven crabs as the reception the other
guys this is my wedding this is
important to me no more jokes you're
right and we're sorry yeah we love you
buddy
warts and all sorry I made a rash
decision I was itching to say it okay
I'm done I have an STD what is all this
no I think Halloween is for jerks
well this Halloween I was the jerk I'm
sorry about tonight
I'm sorry about tonight we found the
title for Santiago's follow-up sex tape
I'm sorry I couldn't convince you to
love Halloween
it's not your fault I was terrible it's
not your fault I was terrible is also
one of your sex tapes
Halloween is unbearable
but it was slightly less unbearable with
you don't I'm a frontrunner for a job in
the Boston PD Boston but it's so close
to Salem you do know what they do to
witches up there don't you this is
amazing
oh my god Amy that's so cool you still
live with your grandmother I live alone
this is my stuff I like quilts stop each
sentence is getting fatter weak blast of
cold air coming out of that box name of
Amy's sex tape hey man come on not cool
I'm going through something just let me
have this one how to go with Miller
fantastic you love me I would give you
more details but someone just came in to
try and find her Dalmatian coat hello
Raymond Madeline I wondered why all the
birds had suddenly stopped singing what
brings her here I heard you're under
investigation by internal affairs in
want to miss that so much time with your
here to the pavement it's a pity a truck
hasn't run over your head and the next
phase of my plan you knocked out your
two front teeth false teeth fake blood I
lost my real teeth against that birthday
party and fourth grade you made sure I
didn't remember that it was minute five
of seven minutes in heaven with Todd
Cohen when he bumped the wall and the
bowling ball fell on my face maybe I
just wasn't at that party was I'd fake
the skating mishap I swapped out a dummy
plaque for the real one and I left to go
to the dentist you can fix your dentist
to help you carry out the rest of the
heist no of course not going I came back
wearing the perfect disguise to make
sure I was never noticed by anyone
something so drab and uninspired feels
like it's gonna be a dig on me I wore
Amy's clothes there it is this is your
doing you and your male prostitute bill
is not a male prostitute I don't think
that suit is not drab it has a fun
salmon lining no Amy it made me
invisible well the competition looks
even older in person what do you think
these dinosaurs are talking about where
to find Matlock reruns be professional
Gina like the homecare nurses who will
into bed tonight oh hello John Raymond I
just want to say what an honor it is to
be up for the same job as a man with
your experience thank you I paused
suggestively before it said experience
so he would know it wasn't really a
compliment who are you talking to
Raymond holt
I'm captain Olivia Crawford I'm the new
candidate for commissioner
well yeah me yeah I replaced the other
candidate he retired to spend more time
with his grandchildren anyway I just
wanted to say what a privilege it is to
be up for the same job as a man with
your tenure no damn she paused you in
error I am certain wuntch hello raymond
you're looking old and sickly so nice of
you to greet us Madeline I thought
surely you'd still be crushed under that
house in Munchkinland
sticks and stones Raymond describing
your breakfast hello captain Holt ah
captain Crawford to what do I owe the
pleasure captain Crawford is here to see
you Thank You Gina
so it would seem that we have become fan
amis do you know what that means are you
trying to imply that I'm too old to
understand a portmanteau I am NOT but I
am too dignified to use one friend enemy
I just wanted to thank you for your
brave speech the mayor's office has
replaced the selection committee with a
less biased one so feel free to start
calling me commissioner now the only
time I plan on calling you is to hear
you concede it's gonna be hard to hear
anything once I've crushed you into a
fine powder a fine powder that will
choke you until you die may the better
candidate win she will
[Music]
[Applause]
what I'm only human you can't always
expect me to be the coolest guy ever
coolest guy ever try telling that Alan
green nice bro
you